PHILADELPHIA.
BEN SIMMONS FROM PHILADELPHIA TO
BROOKLYN.
LOOK AT THE TRADE WITH AMERICAN
EXPRESS JERSEY ASSURANCE.
HARDEN AND MILLSAP GOING TO THE
60sORS AND SETH CURRY AND ANDRE
DRUMMOND AND BEN SIMMONS WITH
PICKS GOING BROOKLYN'S WAY.
HOW DID THIS SHAKE OUT, CHRIS?
>> I THINK THIS WAS SOMETHING
THAT BROOKLYN NETS NEEDED TO DO.
I'VE BEEN FOLLOWING THE NETS
LAST THREE WEEKS DOING SIDELINES
WITH TNT AND LOOKING AT THE BODY
LANGUAGE ON THE NETS TEAM THEY
WERE EXHAUSTED.
JAMES HARDEN SAGA HAD WORN ON
THEM.
IT GOT TO A POINT IT WAS
AFFECTING THEIR PLAY ON THE
BASKETBALL COURT BECAUSE THEY
KNEW THAT HE WASN'T ALL IN.
AND YOU GUYS KNOW THAT, YOU
KNOW, ONCE YOU HAVE A PROMINENT
FIGURE ON THE ROSTER THEY DON'T
FEEL LIKE THEY ARE GETTING HIS
ALL, IT HAS AN EFFECT ON THE
REST OF THE TEAM.
I THINK BROOKLYN NETS FELT LIKE
SOMETHING THEY COULDN'T KEEP
OVER THEIR HEADS OF THE REST OF
THE SEASON AND MADE A DEAL FOR
BEN SIMMONS.
I SPOKE WITH BEN SIMMONS AGENT.
HE IS LOOKING FORWARD TO THE
OPPORTUNITY AND HE ALSO SPOKE
WITH KEVIN DURANT AND KYRIE
IRVING AND HE IS LOOKING FORWARD
TO IT AND THEY WILL TAKE TIME TO
GET HIM ACCLIMATED.
BOTH SIDES ARE GETTING A FRESH
NEW START AND I THINK MORE
BENEFICIAL THEM DOING IT NOW AS
OPPOSED TO DOING IT THE IN
OFF-SEASON BECAUSE I WAS TOLD BY
FRONT OFFICE RIVALS THAT
POSSIBLY THERE WOULD BE SOME
COMPLAINTS ABOUT TAMPERING
BECAUSE JAMES HARDEN IS SO CLOSE
TO SIXERS CO-OWNER MICHAEL
RUBIN.
POSSIBLY FELT BACK DOOR CHANNELS
GOING DOWN.
IT MADE IT ALL MORE SENSE TO GET
THIS DEAL DONE NOW.
SO WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
>> STEVE NASH WAS ASKED A
QUESTION THE OTHER DAY WOULD
JAMES HARDEN BE TRADED.
HE REPLIED NO.
WAS THIS TRADE A SHOCKER TO
JAMES HARDEN OR DID HE KNOW OR
DID HIM AND HIS AGENT KNOW HE
WAS GETTING TRADED?
>> I DON'T KNOW IF THEY KNEW FOR
SURE BUT, OBVIOUSLY, THEY KNEW
THINGS WERE IN THE WORKS A FEW
DAYS RIGHT NOW.
AGAIN, I WAS AROUND THIS NETS
TEAM THE LAST THREE WEEKS.
AND KEPT DOWNPLAYING THE FACT
THAT JAMES HARDEN IS NOT WANTING
TO LEAVE WHEN EVERYBODY ELSE WAS
FEELING OTHERWISE.
THEY KEPT SAYING THAT HE
COMMITTED TO THE ORGANIZATION
AND THAT WAS A TALKING POINT
THAT THEY WERE TRYING TO RELATE
TO EVERYBODY AND THEY WERE
DOWNPLAYING THE HOOPLA COMING
OUT.
BUT IT WAS SERIOUS HOOPLA.
JAMES DID WANT OUT.
YOU KNOW?
HE DIDN'T FEEL THE FIT WAS RIGHT
FOR HIS TALENTS AT THAT TIME.
AND FELT LIKE THIS WAS THE BEST
MOVE FOR HIM AND HIS CAREER
RIGHT NOW.
>> YOU KNOW, CHRIS, THIS IS A
FASCINATING TRADE, IN MY
OPINION.
I HAVE ZERO IDEA WHAT IS GOING
TO HAPPEN.
I DON'T KNOW HOW EMBIID AND
HARDEN GOING TO FIT TOGETHER
BECAUSE JAMES IS A DOMINANT BALL
GUY AND EMBIID IS THE MVP SO
FAR.
BUT, ALSO, YOU FLIP IT TO
BROOKLYN.
YOU GOT BEN WHO WON'T SHOOT.
KYRIE WHO ONLY PLAY IN HALF OF
THE GAMES.
HOW IS THAT THING GOING TO WORK
WITH -- WHEN K.D. COMES BACK?
LIKE IT'S GOING TO BE -- IN SOME
GAMES, HE'LL BE -- JOE HARRIS IS
GOING TO COME BACK.
A LOT OF GAMES, IT'S REALLY ONE
ON FIVE.
>> CHUCK, WE STILL DON'T KNOW IF
JOE HARRIS IS COMING BACK THIS
SEASON.
HE IS STILL LOOKING AT HOW HE IS
GOING TO THE HANDLE HIS ANKLE
INJURY.
WITH THAT BEING SAID, I THINK
THE BROOKLYN NETS FEEL WE GET AN
ALL-STAR PLAYER.
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS AN ALL-STAR
PLAYER HAS -- ON THE OFFENSIVE
END BUT WE GET HIM IN.
A GUY THAT WANTS TO BE THERE,
MOST IMPORTANTLY.
AND A GUY WHO IS ABLE TO PLAY AS
SOON AS THEY GET HIM ACCLIMATED.
I THINK THEY LOOK AT THE LEAGUE
AND REALIZE THAT THIS WAS THEIR
BEST OPTION.
THIS WAS THE BEST OPTION THAT
THEY HAD OUT THERE AND IT DIDN'T
MAKE SENSE TO MAKE A MOVE IN THE
OFF-SEASON.
YOU GOT TO GIVE BROOKLYN CREDIT
FOR, YOU KNOW, THEY GOT ANDRE
DRUMMOND, SETH CURRY.
THEY WANTED MATISSE THYBULLE IN
THERE AS WELL.
I SPOKE WITH THYBULLE'S AGENT
AARON AND ERIC GOODWIN AND THIS
THEY WERE ON ELTON BRAND OF THE
SIXERS AND MAKING SURE, YOU SURE
YOU WANT TO DO THIS?
THIS IS THE NUMBER ONE DEFENDER
STATISTICALLY IN THE LEAGUE.
AND SO THE SIXERS WERE ABLE TO
KEEP THYBULLE OUT OF THAT DEAL.
IT'S GOING TO BE TOUGH.
I DON'T KNOW IF THIS PROPELS THE
NETS TO, LIKE, MAKING THAT NEXT
STEP.
BUT IT'S DEFINITELY A PLAYER
THAT THEY CAN WORK WITH, NOT
JUST IN THIS SEASON, BUT NEXT
SEASON TO TRY TO MAKE THAT
CHAMPIONSHIP COURSE AND
ELIMINATE DISTRACTIONS.
>> CHRIS, I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'VE
ASKED THE EXECS ESPECIALLY IN
BROOKLYN THIS QUESTION.
IS THIS A NEXT YEAR MOVE?
IF YOU'RE THINKING OF BROOKLYN?
IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT WINNING A
CHAMPIONSHIP, THAT WAS THE THING
THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO HAPPEN THIS
YEAR IN BROOKLYN.
AND NOW YOU HAVE LIKE CHARLES
SAID CAN ONLY PLAY IN HALF THE
GAMES, THE ONES ONLY ON THE
ROAD.
YOU HAVE A GUY WHO HASN'T PLAYED
IN HALF A SEASON OR MORE,
THREE-QUARTERS OF A SEASON.
SO YOU HAVE ANOTHER -- YOU HAVE
YOUR BEST PLAYER HAS NOT PLAYED
IN THE LAST 10, 15 GAMES.
IS THIS A NEXT YEAR MOVE AS YOU
ASK THAT QUESTION?
OR NO, WE GOING FOR THE
CHAMPIONSHIP THIS YEAR?
>> I THINK YOU HAVE TO BE
REALISTIC WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT A CHAMPIONSHIP THIS YEAR.
IS IT POSSIBLE?
YES, IT IS POSSIBLE, BUT YOU
HAVE TO WORK BEN SIMMONS INTO
THE FOLD AND THAT IS GOING TO
TAKE WEEKS, MAYBE A MONTH.
WE DON'T KNOW HOW LONG IT'S
GOING TO TAKE HIM TO GET BACK
IN
THE FOLD AND NOT JUST THAT BUT
PLAYING HIS LEVEL OF BASKETBALL.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT IS
HAPPENING WITH THE NEW YORK CITY
MANDATE, IF THAT RESTRICTION
WILL BE LIFTED AND KYRIE WILL BE
ABLE TO PLAY IN A HOME GAME.
THERE IS A LOT TO COVER THERE.
TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION, KENNY,
I THINK YOU HAVE TO LOOK INTO
NEXT SEASON AND SAY, OKAY, I
THINK THE SITUATION WITH KYRIE
WILL BE RESOLVED AT THAT POINT.
BEN SIMMONS WILL BE UP TO FORMAT
AT THAT POINT.
YOU GOT TO LOOK TOWARD THE
FUTURE.
THE PROBLEM YOU HAVE WITH JAMES
HARDEN YOU COULDN'T LOOK TO THE
FUTURE BECAUSE I THINK IF THINGS
WOULD HAVE GONE REALLY HAYWIRE
THIS SEASON, YOU KNOW, JUST
HAVING JAMES HARDEN ON THAT TEAM
THIS WHOLE SEASON, EVERYBODY
KNOWS HE IS NOT BOUGHT IN AND
EVERYBODY KNOWS HE IS A FEW
MONTHS AWAY FROM DEPARTING AND
THEN THEY KNEW THAT DEFINITELY
HE WASN'T COMING BACK NEXT
SEASON.
SO I THINK THIS IS A MOVE FOR
THE FUTURE FOR THE NETS.
>> ONE MORE THING ON THIS TRADE
AND THEN WE WILL MOVE ON.
YOU TALK ABOUT BEN SIMMONS
ACCLIMATING.
I CAN UNDERSTAND THAT NEW
SYSTEM, ET CETERA.
BUT FROM TALKING TO RICH PAUL,
DO YOU GET THE IMPRESSION THAT
EMOTIONALLY, BEN SIMMONS COULD
PLAY RIGHT NOW?
>> I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO
THAT, ERNIE, TO BE HONEST WITH
YOU.
I WILL SAY THIS.
YOU KNOW, HE IS STILL GOING TO
BE SEEING HIS THERAPIST AND
TRYING TO GET HIMSELF MENTALLY
RIGHT, BUT DEFINITELY THIS IS A
BREATH OF FRESH AIR FOR HIM.
HE IS LIKE -- HE HAS LOST A LOT
OF MONEY AS YOU GUYS KNOW WITH
THE FINES AND EVERYTHING IN NOT
PLAYING.
THIS IS A HUGE WEIGHT OFF OF HIS
SHOULDER.
SO HIM GOING INTO A FRESH START
AND PLAYING FOR A PLAYER AND
TEAM THAT HE TRUSTS.
HE FEELS LIKE HE TRUSTS THEM
RIGHT NOW.
THE BIG THING WITH BEN, TRUST IS
REALLY BIG.
HE HAS A SMALLER INNER CIRCLE
AND THAT IS DUE BECAUSE HE
DOESN'T TRUST A LOT OF PEOPLE.
HE FEELS EVERYTHING IS MOVING IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
AND THAN SO, YOU KNOW, I EXPECT
BEN, LIKE I SAID, I EXPECT IT TO
TAKE SOME TIME TO GET BACK IN
THE FORM, GET BACK TO ACCLIMAT